wir kriegen einfach mal auf play und
sehen kennt ihr das wenn ihr euch so die
videos von youtube anschaut und einfach
nur denkt hey was sind das denn
eigentlich für spass tten ich denke dass
beispielsweise immer wenn ich mir den
kanal von diesem konkreter anschaue was
ist das eigentlich für ein spaß
besonders heutigen video widme ich all
diese youtube an die auch zu
beschissenen konnten machen wie dieser
kontrast und jetzt suchen diese jungs
mal wieder besuchen video zu verdienen
ich habe bei twitter geschrieben es
schickt immer wirklich schlechte dumme
bescheuerte youtube videos bei denen man
einfach nur mit dem kopf schütteln
musste kam halt so den 90 prozent der
fälle hat wirklich main kanal als
antwort auf dem kanal von crafter findet
man ganz viel glaube der kanal heißt
konnte luca da kann man sich sehr gut
bedienen
dann kannst du dir mal den ganzen kann
diesen kraft angucken der youtube kanal
von kraft da
ja
danke auf jeden fall an euch dieses
video heute möchte ich youtube videos
finden wo man sich einfach nur denkt
diese youtuber die diese videos macht
haben müssen gestoppt werden weil es so
dumm hält deswegen wir schauen jetzt mal
ernsthaft so ein paar sachen durch also
donald trump erpresst mich
euro um bitte lösche dieses video was
bekomme ich dafür 100 kilo spinner also
pro unter jedem video chat kommt
sagehorn muss gestoppt werden was
schauen was wir sonst noch so ein
gesendet wurde
dieser effekt ist ein ganz schlimmer
geht oft im kontrast einen hahahaha alle
gelacht lukaschik mit dümmel videos teil
8 und dann schickt er mir dumme videos
ja gucken uns
[Musik]
was lieber user mit dem kanal alessi
adriano was das ist sogar von dirty
white plains ich gerade ich weiß nicht
ob das die minis kommen kannst du canal
das kann aber ich verfolge das nicht so
aber dort wild paint muss gestoppt
werden wir schauen was hier noch so ein
gesendet wurde
schauen wir bei kundschaft a whole fails
compilation raum ist voll
howard ist
wie schon lange nicht mehr geguckt ich
habe heute ist eigentlich geben und mit
40 millionen
die hat mit einem video mehr gemacht als
ich im monat mache und davor der werbung
auch kein baby in ordnung macht nur noch
170 ceps am tag wie wie ist die dan
abgerutscht alter die hatten mal
irgendwie 3000 oder so gemacht 2000
jahre später die werbung ist jetzt
endlich mal zu ende meine damen und
herren das heißt wir können uns jetzt
mal ganz kurz das licht gegeben
ok reicht schon wieder die bewertungen
sind auf jeden fall auch mega gut wieder
hier schaut uns mal ein paar kommentare
darunter an der teufel freut sich nicht
auf baby gott auch nicht bei ihrer
beerdigung laufen die leichen wegfegt
ich bin wieder auf mit dieser scheiße ja
sie hat einen scheißdreck raus gewahrt
das hätten sie nie machen sollen ja das
war schon ein bisschen zu hart ist
scheiße was zum teufel wär leicht so
eine scheiße zwar uniqa gabler espanyol
warum kommen dort
6 du willst geht kommentiert sex herz
was ist los mit den menschen
ich finde gerade wirklich keinen
kommentar irgendwie positiv gemeint ist
aber ich muss auch wirklich dazu sagen
baby
ja dieses youtube alles muss gestoppt
werden mein fantreffen eskaliert mit der
polizei ich hasse das
warum macht man das darf bella oder war
es nicht kennen sich hier nicht eher
173000 abonnenten
aber die dislike sind auf jeden fall
auch schon krank am start viele sagten
dass ich das fantreffen heute wegen den
geschenkideen geburtstag geschenke das
stimmt einfach gar nichts diese distanz
denke ich meine es ernst
einfach schenken obwohl ich das nicht
will ihnen müssten ich schenke mich
macht dieses vertreten einfach nur er
macht dieses fantreffen einfach nur
ja er macht dieses feld treffen einfach
nur ich kenne ihn persönlich nicht
deswegen will ich ihnen da gar nicht
irgendwie angehen aber wir sehen es zum
blog anscheinend also er sitzt jetzt
wegen der bahn im wahn gekommen ist nur
noch in der bahn ist wieder in frage
kommen hier findet er seine protestieren
paar leute jetzt findet das für ein
treffen statt wisse was ich nicht
stecken
dass die polizei und die machen einfach
gar
wieso sollen die was machen hier machst
du jetzt fotos mit seinen ganzen leuten
jetzt wird es schwarz jetzt macht er
wieder fotos wieder froh jetzt wieder
schwarz weiß kontrast oder vhs kühle der
videos keine ahnung für mich erzählt der
typ irgendwie so wie pablo und so paar
leute nach kuba teils sogar wirklich
polizei gerade warum findet er wenn der
sturm in polizeiwagen gesetzt ich weiß
nicht wer ist ich weiß nicht was er
macht ich will ihnen hier nicht
irgendwie persönlich attackieren aber
ich war ja solche videos halt überhaupt
nicht von wegen
skaliert und polizei es ist alles so
scheiße stoppt des bka
schauen wir immer weiter was den luxus
ich wurde gehackt irgendwas widgets
kinder abholt der echte auf fische
musikvideo geht es gut
[Musik]
irgendwie handelt das lied nur von
[ __ ] der user das hochland hat nähe
horror und schon wieder aufholen muss
noch einmal gestoppt werden mädchen
frist joghurt und furzt das sind so die
videos auf die ich in youtube
deutschland gewartet habe dadurch dass
ich jetzt das video angeschaut habe
mädchen frist joghurt und kurz bekomme
ich den nächsten zwei wochen
wahrscheinlich in den empfehlungen von
youtube user videos wo mädchen kurzen
will
im ersten linie 4 kam muss gestoppt
werden schreit wir mal jetzt in die
kommentare welchen youtuber ihr stoppen
würde also wenn ihr das recht bekommen
würde irgendein youtuber den total hast
oder so sagen zu können ja der muss auch
von videos machen welcher wäre das
wenn man jetzt in kommentare mich sehr
interessieren ko-tropfen also hier wurde
jetzt nur noch scheiße kommentiert einem
ich hab dann aber nochmal gespielt jetzt
mal im herren schicken videos die
einfach mega zum test on geben sind also
wirklich einfach dumme aussagen oder so
natürlich soll dieses heutige video hier
ist ein bisschen humorvoll sein und ich
glaube jeder weiß dass das dem nutzer
castrisch gemeint ist sich einig habe
nichts gegen horror hohen ich habe
nichts gegen ihre oder wieder typ a ist
aber ich habe einfach keine video hier
und habe mir gedacht hey hier sehen wir
auch wieder so den intelligenzquotienten
meiner community
da wird bei twitter geschrieben wie kann
man den link schicken eingeben
david mehrere windkanal geschickt dass
es auf jeden fall auch cool aber wir
gehen einfach mal auf den kanal von
revidiert auf und sehen enthält bezahlte
promotion jetzt ist der ort auch so ein
werbevideo macher wie kontraste jeder
war das neueste video von rovinj zeit
ist einen idiotentest mit montana black
nachgemacht von crafter ich finde ich
auch noch wie ein tag herr schwarz hallo
sie sind hier wegen dem test nämlich ab
wie du bist du als spaß die witze höchst
definitiv gestoppt werden hier wurde mir
ein video von mir eingeschickt also da
schauen wir uns das mal als nächstes an
pole hofft die kleinsten hieß es der
welt also wirklich einfach mal auf play
und meinte miguel kabel und ich letztes
noch dass er sich irgendwie vom content
her ein bisschen weiter entwickeln will
[Musik]
hat super geklappt egal ob du irgendwie
gehört er will wir haben versprachen
oder irgendwie sonst was also ich weiß
nicht ob das jetzt wirklich feststeht
ist wenn man irgendwas über schuhe kippt
weil ich mach selber nicht die besten
videos aber ich kündige halt nicht
anders ich besser machen macht dann noch
beschissen wäre aber gut wie gesagt
nichts gegen die leute hier persönlich
ich kenne ihn nicht er kann ein echtes
mensch der welt sein ich wage es zu
bezweifeln
[Musik]
das parkett auf welche miniatur schuhe
und ich liebe es in drop musik einmal
der can't stop auf die schule fällt
denke ich war das ganze mal
nachzustellen
leute ich habe hier wohl und ich muss
sagen ich schaue ich jetzt einfach mal
auslastung war seiten bereichert die
leute alter schrauben
[Musik]
o
stoppt wie gelb tableau kommen wir nun
zu einem video was mir nicht allzu
häufig ein gesendet wurde gerade auf
twitter allerdings so ein bisschen der
auslöser deswegen weil sie dieser
baustein dieser grundstein für dieses
video hier waren letztlich so auf
youtube unterwegs und hab halt in meine
empfehlung in diesem video gesehen von
einem youtuber dennis kannte ich jetzt
vorher so noch nicht gemacht hat zu
videos wie der beste fußballer der welt
will cisco in real life ich will cisco
in real life ist es nicht doppelt
gemoppelt ich teste wie bis neun tiere
gefährlich also so bisschen her von den
titel und von den ideen auch so ein
bisschen wie max und ich habe allerdings
ein video dann angezeigt bekommen was
heißt denn erste mordanschlag gegen mich
seht ihr sogar schon dass ich mir das
ein bisschen angeschaut habe leute was
geht ich bin dennis und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video von mir
ihr seht ihr schon am titel heute das
video hier ist ein nicht lustiges video
sondern moment schaut es da mal den
anfang an und seine gesichtsausdrücke so
ein bisschen junge leute was geht ich
bin wahrscheinlich bist du überhaupt
nicht lustig drauf gerade um ehrlich zu
sein bin ich mir dieses video hier gar
nicht komplett anschauen weil ihr seht
schon er hat 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 werbeanzeigen
das ist schon eine menge ist mein ich
habe selber diese standardeinstellung
dass sich eine werbeanzeige vor dem
video habe und wenn sie war zehn minuten
geht danach in video und dann dazwischen
schalte ich allerhöchstens drei wenn ich
weiß dass ich über vier stunden oder so
im schnitt daran saß aber das hier ist
ein video wo er einfach vor der
verdammten kamera sitzt er hat einfach
eine datei und erzielt hier einfach
irgendwas er macht keine großartigen
anstalten dran zoomen keine effekte
einfach nichts
er muss quasi nur katz setzt und die
ganze zeit musik dahinter packen ich
will mich überhaupt nicht vom schnitt
level herüber ihnen stellen oder so aber
allein was ich alles gerade für dateien
habe man mit dran und suchen mit allen
möglichen und planer sehen sind nicht
vollkommen legitim wenn sich leute mit
ihren videos geben da halt auch
dementsprechend werbung zu schalten
das finde ich bei den fällen bei felix
von der laden bei oskar beitragsfrei
sippel bei keine ahnung wem da weiß ja
immer die geben sich mühe und da finde
ich das vollkommen legitim oder mag ich
das aber hier finde ich das überhaupt
nicht klar genauso wie bibi und julian
da schickt einfach kein aufwand hinter
dem videos aber gut
ich habe das video trotzdem nicht zuende
angucken weil er halt in 15 minuten
irgendwie erklärt dass mordanschlag
gegen ihn passiert ist ist es
wahrscheinlich elo klick bett also das
ist jetzt wirklich ein mordanschlag war
oder so glaube ich jetzt eher weniger
die bewertungen geben mir da mehr oder
weniger auch rechts würde aber sagen wir
schauen uns einfach mal ein paar
kommentare unter dem video an und zwar
bei 60 km rad tut er sich nicht wer
alles klar wtf wann sagt jemand dass er
sich nicht wehgetan hat junge akkordeon
und sogar der dennis selbst geschrieben
ich weiß trotzdem nicht was der
kommentar bedeuten soll
bale der woche klick welt ich schwöre
das war wie im film wo man hört auf mit
dem dreck league baseball der woche
mordanschlag weiß nicht was man machen
sollte wenn man dich sieht sie den
pullover aus und kauft der red bull
trikot passt besser zu dir lügen kann er
löscht sich alle melden so was gehört
nicht auf youtube und anstatt das tennis
darauf eingeht und sagt ja es tut mir
leid ich werde das nicht noch mal machen
sagt er danke für das ganze positive
feedback von euch das ist auf jeden fall
massig vorhanden lieber dennis an der
stelle würde ich sagen
stoppt dennis
das war es jetzt vom video meine damen
und herren wie gesagt habe ich euch
einfach mal auf twitter gesagt welche
videos findet ihr so richtig bescheid
wenn er von youtube jemand einfach nur
stoppen sollte natürlich das ganze
wirklich mit einem humorvollen
hintergrund also ich hoffe ihr versteht
hast wahrscheinlich kommen morgen wieder
zehn videos von miguel pablo über mich
von wegen ich würde ihn ja so ist und
fertig machen und dann macht er denn es
auch noch einen sagen ich habe
mordanschlag gegen ihn gehört aber wenn
euch das video hier gefallen hat dann
will ich mich auf jeden fall über like
freunde findet die videos auf die ich
reagiert habe in der beschreibung
eingeblendet und ihr findet jetzt
außerdem hier um einen smiley angemeldet
werde darauf könnte meinen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren verpasst natürlich
keine videos mehr nach oben findet auch
meinen shop eingeblendet in dem neue
klamotten gelaunched sind vor einiger
zeit und hier unten
er hat gedacht ein anderes video ich bin
weg